yeah this will do you guys ready
I'm already Hoss
hey let's suit up
I prefer to keep it simple unlike Mary
Ellen over you still need to shave when
when you said suit up you meant like
right now I'm hungry
yes now we've been suiting up for 20
minutes I mean am I the only one who
suits up one leg at a time
well yeah it's a skirt so I don't have
to deal with legs and zippers and stuff
like that okay
[Music]
well the good news is this is the part
of the Q&A we're gonna focus entirely on
Batman you're gonna lay out the entire
story to us what could you tell us where
are you in the processor he's really
great having this conversation so
aligning what's that
are you still outlining it hitting no
just-just-just well no no I I was
kidding but but I mean where are you
just Eddie's see right here I'm right
here honey man are you outlining are you
scripting are you I am I'm I'm out I
have I have the story worked out and I'm
outlining yeah and I was a huge Batman
fan and I had actually the same medium
there were these dolls when I was a kid
by Mego I was captivated by by him and
and him as a character and just I had
all the toys I had the Batmobile from I
don't know it was dinky or Corgi but
this amazing old cars and that kind of
stuff and I think I think what's
interesting to me is that you know right
now Hollywood is making a very narrow
band of movies right everything is about
a franchise about a pre-existing
property and that very highly personal
point of view driven mode what I see in
Batman that I find so interesting is
that in a way he reminds me of Caesar in
that he is a character with a really
troubled past who is grappling within
himself to try and find the way to do
the right thing in a really imperfect
world in a corrupt world and I find that
that provides an opportunity again if
you want to take that point of view
storytelling and I could imagine the
stories being like a noir you know like
heavily point-of-view driven I mean the
originals were from the Golden Age were
they were detective stories yeah exactly
and I think that if you can marry that
with the personal that there's a chance
to do something very exciting so again I
see an opportunity to do something that
might be hard to do in another way in
the studio system and if you're going to
make a movie in the studio system I find
that this kind of filmmaking can be very
exciting yeah okay
do you have favorites Batman story arcs
sure yeah I do
but III think well also I would want to
get into that now because if I do then
in every speculation that we're just
doing that story sure but I can tell you
this that you know we are looking to all
of those and I'm also looking to other
ways that it feels personal like to me
like I said the thing that's interesting
is the ways in which you can connect to
these stories but it's what the what the
genre is a cover for well how it relates
to the world that we're in and so I
think you know I'm gonna draw
inspiration from those stories but I
want it to be something that's rooted in
something that feels not only personal
to me but relevant you know to the time
so you know there were the reports that
negotiations broke down at some point
you guys came back to the table
obviously and made a deal what what that
leaves me curious about is how confident
you feel like you can go in there and do
the story you want to do it DC I
certainly hope so I mean they you know
let's put it this way they I've never
worked with them but my experience with
them so far has been really good and as
I described what I want to do they seem
really excited hey everybody so there's
a whole bunch of DC going on especially
with the Batman movie we're finally
starting to get some updates on where
they are what state of progress the
movies in I know everybody's still
wondering about Ben Affleck so I'll
explain what's going on with that
there's been some more recent
development since the Christmas holiday
so if you are finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything the flash arrow DC TV trailer
is really just meant to remind you that
everything is coming back next week
there'll be separate trailers for that
stuff for each of the different shows
this week so I'll do trailer videos when
possible but I know everybody really
just wants to talk about the Batman
movie so when he says that he's
outlining it right now he already has
the story it just means that he has the
idea and as it was described to me at
the Justice League movie the most recent
version of that reads a lot like mask of
the phantasm with a Robin in it now I
don't know if that's gonna be an older
version of Robin because there's all
these rumors about Jake Gyllenhaal being
Batman so that would necessitate a much
younger version of the Robin character
but as awesome as it is to hear that
they're planning on making a
Hitchcockian Batman detective thriller
that feels like baska the phantasm
what does
that mean for the Nightwing movie
because that's confirmed Dick Grayson
there is no other version of Nightwing
that is not Dick Grayson
there are several Robins that they could
roll out for the Batman movie and then
there's the question of a where it fits
in the timeline because the way that
Matt Reeves has described it in the past
when he talked about being connected not
connected is that when the studio
pitched him the idea of doing a Batman
movie he would just have to worry about
the Batman character he wouldn't have to
worry about all this crazy Darkseid
stuff that they were setting up during
Justice League so even though Jeff John
said that all the movies are still
connected it does feel like this Batman
movie whoever winds up being the Batman
character in it will be relatively
self-contained even though within the
world of the movie all the other Justice
League characters will exist it just
sounds like Batman will have his problem
to solve and it's not like he's going to
check in with all the different
characters of the Justice League to get
help with his problem it's something
that he'll take care of himself with any
other Batman characters that they want
to include in that the only real update
that we have about Ben Affleck is that
he was taking meetings at the studio
after the Christmas holiday so he could
be meeting with Warner Brothers about
anything but what a lot of people are
saying is is that because like Matt
Reeves says that they have the story but
not the actual script is that Ben
Affleck is waiting for the script to
decide whether or not he wants to be in
that movie so all the talk that you hear
about the studio pursuing other actors
is just them hedging their bets because
they don't want to wait even longer to
make the movie there's been enough
delays like originally I think they
intended to release it 2018 2019 but
then Ben Affleck said that he never
really found a script that he was happy
with so then they had to pursue another
director which is when Matt Reeves came
on so he negotiated the right to do his
own story which he's in the process of
writing the script for right now so you
have to add another six months a year
before they're done with that and they
don't want to get a year down the road
and have Ben Affleck read the script and
say you know what I don't feel like
doing this movie and then have to wait
another six months to a year to find the
right actor so typical movie turnaround
I don't think that we see this Batman
movie that Matt Reeves is making before
2020 but we'll probably get some more
updates about that after
Aquaman comes out most of their energy
is gonna be spent promoting that and
then the next Wonder Woman movie but for
all of you asking about Ben Affleck
flashpoint stuff there aren't any
updates about that they have it locked
down their director yet once they do
that you'll hear the wheels start
turning but you have to remember that
people like Ben Affleck also get script
approval on stuff like that so if he
sees the flashpoint script and wants to
change it that could take a little bit
more time so if you ever wonder why
there are so many delays with movies
it's because of stuff like that like
people coming in and not being happy
with other people's versions of stories
so if you're powerful enough you get the
opportunity to do the story that you
want to do but later tonight good news
there's gonna be new black panther
footage dropping obviously I'll do a
video for it also try to get a new Star
Trek discovery video out because that
show just came back and they did some
really big stuff there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter just be a subscriber leave a
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from my last DC video cc Oreo
please private message me so I can get
your contact details click here for
brand new flash and click here for brand
new infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight